[Music]
yeah the party last night was awesome so
thanks to Google for that they had Gwen
Stefani there and I realized as I was at
the party that Gwen Stefani is probably
a tech worker and I'm convinced of this
because her last song hollaback girl I'm
convinced that that song is about being
on call cuz she ain't no hollaback girl
so she doesn't want to be on call and
she says this is bananas ba na na s and
I think that explains pretty much all of
our systems that we build which is why I
want to talk about chaos things are
bananas oftentimes when I'm building
stuff my reaction is either oh my god
that weren't right cuz it's just like I
can't believe this stuff actually works
or it's like oh my god that worked like
you you have a problem your system goes
down and you're like how the hell did
this work in the first place like this
shouldn't even be functioning so chaos
is is about learning about our systems
so more more fun quotes I love this
quote from Barack Obama that says you
can't let your failures define you you
have to learn you have to let your
failures teach you you have to learn
from them which is is what chaos is
really about right our systems break all
the time there's a researcher on safety
named David woods he gets mentioned in a
lot of DevOps sort of circles and he has
this quote that our systems are in a
constant state of failure like failure
isn't binary it's just a spectrum and so
if we if we understand that that we're
failing and that's okay right because we
can learn from it now Barack Obama
talked about a whole lot of things he
talked a lot about hope unfortunately
that's maybe not a good thing so I love
this quote about hope kori Bertram is
the the VP of infrastructure and sre at
data dawg
and he likes to say this that hope is
not a strategy we can't hope that our
systems will stay up we can't hope that
our software will deploy without any
bugs right how many people deployed some
time this week
- played some code deployed
infrastructure spun something up that's
most of us how many people deployed bad
code you had a bug or you deployed
infrastructure and it broke and it's
pretty much the same amount of hands if
you didn't then I don't know good job on
you or maybe you missed something and
you should be really worried so the
other thing about Cori though and the
reason that Cori says this is kori came
from Netflix so use part of the team
started implementing a lot of chaos
around things and so the back story of
this is that Netflix was moving from
on-prem to the cloud and as they were
doing so they realized a lot of things
about the cloud right they realize that
cloud isn't about resiliency even though
Google provides us great SLA is and
they're up most of the time just like us
there are issues and they work to
resolve them but the great thing about
Google cloud is that you can spin up new
new resources all the time right so you
have this ability to constantly have
more resources and that means that
rather than avoiding failure you can
embrace failure you can start planning
for failure and doing things like
rollovers or auto scaling and things
like that so they had a lot of these
lessons in the number one lesson that I
like from this blog post that they
posted was that the best way to avoid
failure is to constantly fail right to
constantly try to fail do those painful
things and then learn from them and this
led them to creating a thing called
chaos monkey who hears heard of chaos
monkey yeah I think we all have at this
point
who here is heard that it's this program
that randomly deletes your servers takes
things down yeah I mean that was the
point right unfortunately I think a lot
of us have believed this and it's if you
go back and read the blog post it's sort
of a myth and I'll dive into that in a
bit so Who am I I don't come from
Netflix
I'm Jason I work at data dawg I'm a
Technical Evangelist which is a really
fun job means I get to come and talk to
people like you I get to help our
customers I get to learn stuff and then
teach people as well a bunch of things
about me I do actually
a hat like that I play a lot of Pokemon
go if you see me wandering around later
I'm not lost a little bit about data dog
data dog is a SAS based monitoring
platform and so we work with Google we
work with your on-prem if you're doing
multi cloud or we work with all the
major cloud providers but we ingest all
of your metrics your traces distributed
traces we collect your logs help you do
log analytics and we we launched a new
synthetics product so essentially we try
to get you all the observability tools
to let you know what's going on in your
systems let you know where you can find
those issues when something does happen
and this is important when it comes to
chaos so back to it to Netflix and
talking about chaos right if you
actually go back to their blog post it
says this that by running chaos monkey
not randomly not at any given time but
in the middle of a business day in a
carefully monitored environment with
engineers standing by well then we can
address those problems and learn the
lessons that we need to learn about the
weaknesses in our systems about how to
build the automatic recovery mechanisms
which is one thing as mentioned that the
cloud an out late enables us to do and
so by doing all of this then maybe at 3
a.m. on on a Sunday on those random
times then we won't even notice right we
can build all these things so lesson 1
from this talk if you come out of here
and you're like yeah I'm gonna go do
some chaos stuff and you're doing it in
the middle of the night and you're not
telling your colleagues and you're
waking them up and then we'll the night
then you're a jerk and my number one
lesson is don't be a jerk right we'll
talk about how to plan these we'll have
talked about how to run these so that
you're actually learning and being a
good colleague so data dog we start with
game days and the main difference
between game days and chaos is that game
days are very much a manual process and
that's where you want to start right you
don't want to just jump into automation
that you don't understand so just like
any game at data dog there are rules
right I was in Italy so this is the
Italian soccer team and I was pointing
out to them that the rules are there to
make the game fun right if you were
playing a
her game and there were no rules well
then I can come up and punch you in the
face and take the ball and run throw it
in the goal and you'd be like hey that's
not soccer that sounds like rugby right
that's it's it's only fun if there are
rules that we all agree upon and so the
rules make things a little less scary
and they let us know what to expect so
the rules of the game day are just like
a soccer match it lasts 90 minutes right
we want a time box this we don't want it
to go on for a full day because then we
lose productivity we don't want things
to just drag on and on so we keep things
nice and short within that 90 minutes we
spend 30 minutes for planning again we
want to keep this short nobody wants to
spend half a day or a day planning what
they're gonna do so 30 minutes nice
short period doesn't take too long then
we spend 50 minutes playing this is the
actual fun part this is where we get to
test our systems this is where we get to
break things and see what happens and
then again ten minutes at the end just
for reporting we don't want this to be
too long again if it's too long for
reporting nobody wants to do it right
that's the boring part of things so the
ten minutes nice and short and I'll dive
into how this works
in a bit but let's talk about the team
every game has teams so our teams are
nice and small we don't want to take up
everybody's time because again we lose
productivity so the team ends up being
two usually two people the first is a
subject matter expert and that's going
to be the developer who built the
service who knows the most about it it
might be the ops engineer who
architected this particular services
infrastructure whoever knows the most
about it that's the person that's going
to be the main player on this team the
next person is going to be someone from
the SRE team so they're gonna partner up
because the sres are really those
experts on how to keep your systems
running how to keep them reliable what
the best practices are all right so now
we can partner up with the person who's
building things a person who essentially
helps ensure that they stay running it's
a good team sometimes though we add a
third player and that third player is
going to be a junior engineer or junior
developer and more often than I like
we have a third player because that
third player this junior engineer is the
person that knows just a little bit
about that service there just a little
about about that infrastructure so when
you take something down and you see some
weird symptoms around that this is the
person that has no idea why that
happened there the person that asks
those questions because there are no
stupid questions but they ask those
questions about why did that happen
right what's going on wait why did we do
that in the code why did we build that
this way and for most of us that have
been around well you're like well of
course I owe ya that's not really the
logical way we did it because there was
this other constraint so that's the
great thing about it the other nice
thing is as a more senior engineer or
developer you get to mentor that person
right now they're seeing the reasons
that you built that service or that
system in a particular way they
understand now when you say oh yeah I
did that weird thing because this
constraint now as a junior engineer when
they come up with strange constraints or
things that they're not familiar with
now they have some reference of like oh
here's a creative way that you did it so
let's talk about those times though
thirty minutes spent planning what do we
do for the thirty minutes well number
one we have to schedule this right we
want to ensure that we have enough time
to do this 90 minutes do not start this
at 4:00 p.m. on a Friday because if it
runs long if something happens it's
eating into your weekend right so plan
it schedule it for at least those 90
minutes but maybe add a little bit of
time in case you need that extra time
then simply you pick your tests you
start easy right figure out what you're
gonna do figure out what you want to
break how you want to break it not too
hard write down what you expect to
happen when that when you do break
things right so think of it as a
scientific experiment what's your
hypothesis if if I take down the data
store what's my service gonna do what
sort of alerting should I receive you
know and your hypothesis does not have
to be and probably shouldn't be every
single time that your service survives
right we'll talk about some of the tests
that we run
but it's it's really not logical to
assume that you can build services that
if you cut off all their critical
dependencies if you drop the network
that they're just gonna keep going
hunky-dory everything's fine right so
write down what you expect to happen
also write down what your plan is what's
your your fallback plan if everything
goes wrong right if you have a cascading
failure let's say you start off in
staging and you're like cool this is
I've got these tests no problem
I don't expect things to fail so you
don't write up a plan and suddenly you
take down all of staging your entire
organization is down nobody can test
code no one can like work well that's a
bad problem so whatever you do write
down your plan B what are you gonna do
if things go wrong and then finally most
importantly share the document not just
to your team not just to the two people
playing you know that other sre that's
with you or if you're the SOE not test
to the engineer or the junior engineer
send it as wide as you can at least to
your entire or engineering organization
all of your developers all of your ops
engineers but even consider more broadly
right if you're starting to do game days
in production send it company-wide right
think about your account managers or
your sales reps if they're out there
talking to a customer and the customer
you know your chaos engineering plan
kind of fell apart and starts to impact
latency on your production systems and
your customers start complaining they're
gonna not complain to you they're gonna
complain to their account reps or the
salespeople right so it's good to share
this information as broadly as possible
because it may impact other people and
it's good for them to know so that's the
30 minutes right nice short planning not
too much involved so what happens during
well during when we actually run the
game days we do start off in staging I
mean you want to start off in a safe
environment and then once it passes
there will promote that and we'll try it
in production during off-peak hours and
then we'll move that to primetime will
we'll run it in production in heavy
times of actual customer traffic
so when we start the game day when we
start the actual playing you want to
announce that and you want to announce
that within your group chat tool
whatever you're using HipChat slack
whatever sort of chat ops tool you're
using because it's so a way to get
things broadly right if I just come into
the room and say hey everyone I'm doing
this well you know Bob might be out
getting coffee he has no idea that that
happened right so we want to announce it
in a tool that everybody has access to
and in a tool that records things
because we want to maintain our
discussions there because if it's me and
an SRE and we're teaming up and we take
down a system and I'm like trying to
type up notes and things are going on
well what did I say five minutes ago I
was talking about this thing that I
observed and then you saw this other
thing if it's all in slack if it's all
in HipChat or whatever you're using now
I have a complete dialogue of everything
that was said and when it comes to
taking notes later then I can just post
a link and say here's what we saw here's
what we were discussing right keep
things nice and easy we also want to
monitor for outages and we do this in
two ways obviously a data dog or a
monitoring company so we have tons of
dashboards you want to keep whatever
monitoring tool you've got open be
monitoring your systems but also we have
an outage channel within within slack
right so we want to keep aware of that
because if anyone declares an actual
outage that's a cue for us to stop what
we're doing right we don't want to add
our game day or a chaos into their
actual real chaos while they're trying
to debug our systems or bring systems
back online so you want to monitor for
that and then finally you play right you
break your systems you run your tests
you take your notes you explore your
systems see what they do for the after
again we want to keep this nice and
short because this is the boring part
it's not the fun part of playing but the
great thing is you know you've taken
notes you have that dialogue within
slack so you just paste the link to that
you create cards and tickets whatever
tracking system you're using whether
that's JIRA or Trello whatever you've
got you write those down the things that
you saw like oh yeah well you broke this
thing are monitored
go off the way we thought it did or I
got an alert but it had useless
information in it so you just create the
tickets right there right make sure that
those get done you write your summary
and the key lessons and the summary is
essentially your notes again you don't
have to spend a whole lot of time you
shouldn't spend a whole lot of time with
this copy your notes in there copy the
link to slack write up some of the
things that you observed those key
lessons those key points that you want
people to take away and then you email
that out right - all of engineering at
least at a very minimum maybe to your
entire organization because again the
whole point about this is learning from
these failures so spreading that
information as far as we can
becomes beneficial and finally the most
important part is you celebrate at day
to dog we love to celebrate anything and
everything any possibility to celebrate
we do including game days right if the
game day goes great and you're like we
expected that our system would be
completely resilient we hammered it with
traffic we essentially DDoS yourself and
it Auto scaled up and handled all that
perfectly or you know our wha factually
blocked that because that's what we were
expecting like great you won you built a
resilient system Congrats you celebrate
that but similarly if I roll out my
chaos experiment and there's a cascading
failure and I take down all of staging
and entire engineering departments mad
at me because everyone has to stop work
well I fix that
but then I celebrate right because I
just learned something that's really
important about our systems I learned
where that critical fault was and now
we're on the road to fixing that right
so you want to celebrate everything when
you do these so let's talk about the
tests that we run we we have five
different levels or six because we'd
number with zero but the first is to
terminate the service right if I turn
off this service and I just restart it
does it actually restart does it restart
without any human intervention right if
if I have to restart my server and then
login and enter some credentials because
I'm not using you know a secrets manager
well that's a bad thing if I restart my
application and because I did that
because it was down my my router isn't
actually sending traffic to that well
great if your service is up but not
receiving traffic that's a bad thing
right so really simple terminate your
service the other thing we do at this
level is block access to one critical
dependency so whatever that is if it's
you know your you've got a build system
and it needs to load libraries or other
components block that what happens with
your build system if it's you know a
service that has a persistent data store
what happens if you block access to that
data store again it doesn't have to
survive right if I have a user login
service and I block access to that data
store and people can't log in well
that's not great but at least that's
what I should expect right and if that's
what I expect and that's the way that
the service operates well then that's a
good thing from there we level up we
block access to all the dependencies and
again we want to ensure that it acts the
way we we expected to not that it
survives if it survives that's amazing
but you know we want it we want to
ensure that it expects the way we do so
we want to verify that errors are
reported right that we have proper
monitoring on that that if we block all
those those dependencies we should at
least get some sort of alert and that
automated alert should go to my team it
should have links to my dashboards it
should have links back to to some sort
of documentation with with a run book
that says if this happens here's what
you look at here's what you try to do to
resolve that the next level up is we
terminate the entire host right so we
take down that node or that VM and we
see if it fails over to another one
hopefully it does we verify that that
traffic gets redirected to that new host
right because we don't want to have to
manually do that this also helps us
guarantee that hosts are replicated
across availability zones and that
similarly their data stores are
replicated as well level three is we
that we degrade the environment so we're
starting to get a little more complex
here but we
do things like slow down the network
start dropping packets introduce jitter
we want to verify here that you know we
can we can survive this or that at least
if that data is coming in and it's
incomplete because we've missed packets
that our systems can now start to maybe
retry those or at least identify that
it's gotten malformed information we
also want to verify that we have what I
call let's so Google awhile back there s
re team wrote the the Google s re
handbook it's published by O'Reilly and
they have this thing called the four
golden signals which it's a hi nice
lofty name I never remember what it is
so I realized it and said let's let's is
a nice acronym for latency errors
traffic and saturation latency are we
seeing increases in latency do we have
proper monitoring for that errors are we
monitoring what sort of errors were
receiving what's the error rate traffic
are we seeing more traffic or less
traffic and we want to monitor that in
both ways right if I'm seeing more
traffic well that could be good it could
mean that whatever we we tried users are
actually engaging more and so we're
seeing higher traffic or it could be bad
that something that we rolled out
something that we're testing is less
than optimal and now we're issuing you
know more requests against the server
similarly saturation do we have enough
resources whether that's compute IO
network the great thing about this
though is once you pass this level once
you're able to survive a degraded
environment once that you're sure that
we have complete monitoring on that that
we've got those metrics that we've
traced this application that we've got
proper logs this is the time when you
can actually handoff to the s re so up
until this point at data dog if you
write a service you write that service
you're responsible for it which means
that you're on call for it you have to
run what you write but at this point
because we know we have full monitoring
on this we've tested that things react
the way we should we think they should
we've got proper alerts that have run
books that tell people even if they
don't know very much about the service
it tells them exactly what they should
do in case of an incident
well that means it's ready to go to an
SRE so now that sre can actually start
to take over some of your on-call
responsibilities which this is a great
great level to get to right means no
more constant on-call you you have
somebody to back you up so you can sleep
better at night level four is where we
spike the traffic so we essentially try
to DDoS our own services what happens
when I receive a ton of traffic
do I have auto scaling turned on is my
service set up to run asynchronously can
I pass those there's jobs off and queue
them and then run them at a later time
and then level five is mass destruction
nuclear outage what happens if we just
nuke Google cloud right can i failover
to an on-prem can i failover to another
cloud provider I do have to copy yet
with saying that at data dog were multi
cloud but not all of our services are at
this level yet right this is the dream
this is where we're we're pushing
towards and actually that Google
announcement anthos that's pretty cool
right you can start to do multi cloud
and they're making it easier so I've
talked about a lot of stuff um I know
it's early and I've seen so that some of
you are like starting to nod off so who
wants to run an experiment yeah all
right so let's switch over and run an
experiment right I'm gonna keep this
nice and easy because it is early but
let's start off with that planning right
this planning it would be normally 30
minutes but because we're in this
session and I have 25 minutes left we
can't actually spend that amount of time
but scheduling it Congrats we're doing
it right now I'm letting you know right
now we're gonna choose a test so I've
got a WordPress site because I think
everybody understands WordPress it's a
nice simple easy thing to do let's kill
my sequel right what happens if
WordPress has no datastore and let's try
a few ways right so I've got it running
in kubernetes so I'm gonna say that the
way we're going to kill this is we can
kill the pod right we can
kill the deployment and then actually
was wondering last night I've never
actually done this but what if I log
into my pod and just like kill - nine
the actual service right so what do we
expect to happen shout it out if you
have a wordpress site and my sequel goes
down what do you think is gonna happen
WordPress is gonna get even slower nice
high latency on WordPress someone said
500 error anything else what can we
expect if I take WordPress and my sequel
down my sequel errors all right what
about alerting
I should receive some sort of alerts
right so cool those are some good things
what are we gonna do if things go
horribly wrong well we're gonna walk
away it's early so I'm probably not
gonna go to a bar and get a beer but if
things go horribly wrong and for some
reason this cascades and takes down the
the Google cloud network then yeah I'm
definitely walking away I may be running
away but maybe we can go get some coffee
and hang out it's cool that's that's it
for planning nice and easy right and
then I share this so this is actually
available online this just I've got the
URL and that'll be in the slides later
cool so just to show you I do have this
WordPress site that's here it looks like
it's operating pretty good and I'm gonna
switch over I've got WordPress running
in just mini cube on my computer here
because I didn't want to tempt the demo
gods but we can see that yes I still
have some pods running right so we go
back to our document and I said what are
we gonna do let's kill the pod right so
if I do
that's delete pod and I'm gonna take
down my sequel here
cool says it's deleted I can come back
here I see an error and then it's back
cool that's pretty much what we expected
right kubernetes is nice and fast at
that so if I just go back up there we
can see that yes it restarted it was
pulling up everything just fine here
right it's got still got my image so you
know my persistent volume claim worked
so things that we saw we can just say
that we killed the pod and it respond as
expected cool super easy right so let's
try what if we delete that deployment
cool so now if I do that we should see
that my pod is terminating it is come
back here we see that ugly error
establishing database so we'll make a
note of that
WordPress and is essentially
non-responsive right unresponsive with
an error and then I should get alerts so
let's see did I actually get an alert
let's go to my monitors I do have an
alert here that my sequel was killed I
want to check in my email if i refresh
here I did get an alert on my email and
it's got some information here which
might be hard for you to read in the
back it says my sequel is killed if this
was not intentional please verify the
kubernetes deployment none more I
checked the kubernetes dashboard so I
can click on that takes me to data dog
loads up my dashboard here you can take
a look at this I see that you know pods
desired pods available 5 so those match
desired and ready so overall it looks
like things are working quite nicely
still on kubernetes which is what we'd
expect then it says check out our team
documentation which I don't have any
example documentation but that's
probably a good thing for us to do and
then it says to restart my sequel ensure
you have the latest llamo files and then
run this command so let's verify that
our instructions in our alert is
actually what we expect right
so I reapply that it looks like those
are unchanged and then it's got my
deployment there so it's recreated that
and if I get my pods it's back up and
running so does this actually run here
cool WordPress is back right exactly as
we expect so we killed that we should
say that we received alerts it had some
steps that worked right so we can fill
this out a little bit more later but
we're just taking notes here anything
that we didn't expect no not yet so we
had one more thing that we wanted to try
and that was up here let's log into the
pot and kill - nine the service and see
what happens so I've got my pod that's
back up and running that in - cool oh
that's fun
sorry oh yeah let's know oh so this is a
fun thing good to know that we are
running maybe I think this is Alpine
which means that they removed that yeah
all right so I'm not gonna dive down
that rabbit hole but that's a good thing
and that's actually something that we
can note here right like we were
actually running running in a minimal
container that doesn't have have PS
right the cool thing about that though
is we probably in this case if we're
running this in production we wanted
some other tools so things that we
should change or fix now as we're taking
notes is we should set up some dev tools
so we can PS on containers right cool
we just learned something and actually
like I hadn't planned this I was just
randomly thinking what what would happen
if I did that this morning cool
so experiment has been run right again
super easy we learned some stuff about
what we're running and then we've got
the lessons learned so again this is the
super short part it should just be ten
minutes we make JIRA tickets
so this is our JIRA ticket right so we
go into JIRA we make that we write a
summary of things we saw things we
didn't expect which essentially is copy
pasting this right and then we share
this
so we're gonna email this out and then
finally we celebrate right so yeah we
ran an experiment it works we learned
some stuff cool so I'm gonna update this
this gist and it's now saved so you guys
have access to it so if we go back to
the slides just a review if I had to
boil this down to three points right
there's all this advice on how you
should run things but at the end of the
day it comes down to this it's sharing
share what you do when you're planning
things out you're sharing that as
broadly in your organization as you can
when you're actually running things
you're sharing that right you're letting
people know that you're running and then
finally you're sharing what you learned
across your organization's number two to
sum this up is to plan right simply just
come up with those experiments plan
those out plan what's gonna happen if
things go horribly wrong and then
finally have fun right we're learning
about things we just learned that we
didn't have PS we don't have the proper
admin tools within our containers so we
need to to plan for that you know have
fun celebrate we just learned that so
you know I wish I could take you all out
and like buy you celebratory beer but
it's also super early so you can
celebrate in your own way a few other
resources though again you know I advise
you to keep things simple right
systemctl kill you know kill - 9 your
services you don't need super complex
fancy tools for this keep things simple
when you're testing them a few other
things that we do use though as we start
to level up I mentioned that you want to
simulate bad Network conditions and so
that's what Comcast is there for it's a
nice tool it is hilarious
I shouldn't say disparaging things about
Comcast but I think we've all
experienced their their ISP services
Vegeta is a nice one if you've ever used
Apache bench which comes with the Apache
web server Apache bench essentially
allows you to simulate traffic Vegeta is
like Apache bench on steroids so it's
written in go you can essentially DDoS
yourself but it's also got some great
tools where when you do that it'll stay
saving up some data and you can pipe
that back into Vegeta and it'll generate
graphs for you so you can actually have
nice summaries of what your you've been
doing a few other things gremlin gremlin
I know they are sponsoring downstairs
but gremlin is chaos as a service they
rolled out a free service which allows
you to essentially do node killing or
service killing and then also CPU tests
as well so those are available freely
they integrate with data dogs so it's
really cool if you do use data dog you
can launch those directly from your
dashboards it lets you know when the
test was running allows you to monitor
your metrics through the course of the
test and then finally Kaos toolkit
another great resource they have a bunch
of information on how to run chaos
experiments a bunch of tools that you
can actually use as well so with that
said open to questions so if you think
of anything afterward you leave here and
you're like oh I wish I knew more about
this feel free to email me or that's my
twitter handle you can tweet at me and
I'll answer those questions as well and
then these slides are available online
and the documents of the experiment that
we just ran those are available and
adjust as well
[Music]